et pour en parler randy aloses avocat et
président de république en over 6 france
et avocat franco américain est avec nous
sur ce plateau randy yalouz bonjour
bonjour merci d'abraxas sion merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation donc
aujourd'hui super cuisse dès on le
disait plus que cinq candidats en lice
est-ce que ce soir on aura le nom de
l'adversaire de donald trump
je pense principalement en droit d'avoir
je pense que si comme je pense que ben
laden va prendre comment une avance
assez important ce soir
et comment ça représente un tiers des
votes au niveau de la primaire donc on
aura vraiment une vision du changement d
attitude parmi les démocrates ont
aujourd'hui vue qui bâille d'années
s'est pas présenté sur un prospective
très favorable lors des premières
primaires et des caucus dont il ya un
mois aujourd'hui avec en caroline du sud
on voit un changement une part d'autre
part on voit aussi qui est des deux
autres candidats modérés soutiennent
maintenant pas daigné se sont désistés
et la course pour la présidentielle donc
il a un appui assez important et je
pense que ce soit on va voir quand même
une appui important des démocrates
or by day bien entendu je sais quoi
c'est aussi un aspect difficile pour
bernie sanders parce que je pense qu'ils
y voit qui est parmi les démocrates
il ya quand même un nombre assez
important qui agit contre lui et qui se
trouve sol contre les autres démocrates
aujourd'hui il ya aussi une question
quelle sera la position de madame ou run
est ce qu elle va appuyer monsieur bart
hayden est ce qu'il va jouer sa carte
éventuellement peut être numéro 2 avec
buydens a aussi peut être une surprise
parce que peut-être les choix des
vice-présidents éventuel peut jouer
aussi en faveur de monsieur bart hayden
alors vous en parlait la pression en
train puis après son retrait petite
boutique neige a donc annoncé apporté
son soutien à joe biden tout comme amy
klobuchar et veto au recours qu est ce
que au fond ce sont des vraiment des
soutiens de poids
je pense et ils ont ainsi qu'un quand
même assez important je pense que
aujourd'hui il ya aussi une question
d'argent
pour financer ses campagnes mais celui
qui cherche aujourd'hui ces rencontres
qui pour avancer il se rend compte qu'il
n'a pas le financement nécessaire pour
confronter ses deux adversaires et sont
les financements et doit mettre fin à
ces sa course pour les primaires
alors justement il ya le milliardaire
michael bloomberg qui rentre en lice
pour ces pour ces primaires est ce qui
peut faire changer la donne je pense
c'est un aspect clé je pense qu'il va
jouer un rôle important je pense pas
qu'yves at il vat les numéros toi mais
en même temps il va jouer un rôle
important pour financer je pense et
venteux monsieur byden et c'est assez
clair par les échanges qu'ils ont eus
qu'il va à soutenir la candidature de
monsieur senders et je pense aujourd'hui
si on voit un avancée importante aux
messieurs byden et que je crois qu'il
est sait se montrer qui il a un rôle à
jouer
je crois qu'ils le montrent ces cartes
et ensuite il va a décidé de soutenir
des candidats démocrates modérés et en
l'espèce ce sera monsieur bart hayden je
pense à fait partie des stages stratégie
après quels seront les exigences de
monsieur bloomberg
on ne connaît pas à ce qu'il dit je il
est contre troy il faut savoir
aujourd'hui on a un républicain qui
était avant le maire de new york et
ensuite il est devenu démocrate donc
encore pour les bases des démocrates
il est quand même les sont méfiants donc
est-ce qu'ils vont accepter une
candidature avec monsieur byden avec des
soutiens financiers
monsieur grübel à voir en tous les cas
un côté républicain quel candidat
on aimerait voir face à donald trump
pour lui c'est la même chose
je pense que monsieur trempe et les
candidats qui favorisé tous les sondages
il a les résultats économiques il va
gagner ces élections
je n'ai pas du tout déçu que ce soit
monsieur byden monsieur centers et de
loin monsieur bloomberg
je ne vois pas
une opposition féroce je pense que on
aura une élection pour notre candidat
qui sera le prochain président et bien
entendu les élections vont démarrer
rapidement là parce que je pense après
aujourd'hui on va connaître bien les
candidats qui sera envisagée pour
l'investiture des dupes aux démocrates
alors pour conclure au coeur des
attentions il ya le texas anciennement
républicains s'il texas tombe
est-ce que donald trump a perdu comme on
a pu l'entendre dans le reportage
j'aime bien parce que j'ai vu ce matin
sur les questions des sondages encore
c'est une question des sondages
si on regarde les sondages faits par les
républicains y voient pas ça comme un
problème d côté démocrate et ceux ci
disent ah oui on est en position dé
reprendre le texas mais moi je pense
nexans par reste républicain je n'ai pas
de difficulté à leader en
devant la télévision et je pense que les
texans sont traditionnellement
république arrive au reste républicain
bien entendu il ya plus de démocrates
mais aujourd'hui c'est un état
traditionnellement républicain était
selon les sondages qui a été fait de
notre côté il va rester merci beaucoup
rendre jalouse d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que cet avocat
franco américain président de république
à 12h06 france merci pour l'invitation
est un plaisir à bientôt